[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors je vous présente
loïc et fania loïc vient de la cité
jardins de suresnes
une de ces milliers de sites et de
quartiers populaires qu'on n'appelle
plus souvent les quartiers sensibles les
quartiers difficiles qui sont riches de
leur diversité mais mais plus connu pour
le décrochage scolaire la délinquance la
violence les trafics de drogue bon loïc
il a 19 ans et a eu son bac il n'avait
pas trop l'école mais mais il a eu son
bac et après le bas qui voulait être
mécanicien cycle mécanicien vélo alors
il a cherché une entreprise et puis
malheureusement il n'a pas trouvé
d'entreprise
alors du coup il a abandonné il a
abandonné il est retourné avec les
copains en bas de la cité pour traîner
comme il dit et il a traîné il a traîné
jusqu'au jour il a croisé un copain qui
l'a emmené à la mission locale du
quartier qu'est la mission locale du
quartier il a croisé la route de moi
mais d'un énorme
un des encadrants d'unicité et la
croisée finalement la route du service
civique et avec une bande d'une
cinquantaine autres jeunes des
hauts-de-seine notamment de suresnes et
pas que de son quartier il a décidé de
donner six mois à faire des choses pour
la communauté
il s'est lancé comme volontaire cinéma
et citoyenneté avec ça sa bande de 50 e
collègue ils ont organisé des débats des
ciné-débats dans les collèges et lycées
ils ont contacté tous les collèges tous
les lycées du quartier des environs ils
ont réussi a quand même organisé une
dizaine de débats eux qui pour certains
avaient encore fait moins d'études que
loïc et comme loyer qu'ils se sont
rendus compte que finalement il était
capable de faire plein de choses et que
en lui il y avait une force qu'il
ignorait que finalement il pouvait être
utile à quelque chose il pouvait servir
à quelque chose dans cette société
et comme il disait souvent la société
dans mon quartier on a l'impression que
pour la paye qu'on la subit chaque jour
on est juste là pour subir la société
est maintenant avec cette expérience de
6 mois
c'est rendu compte qu'ils pouvaient être
acteur de cette société et qu'on
attendait quelque chose de lui et qu'ils
pouvaient apporter quelque chose
alors du coup loïc maintenant il a plein
de projets il veut même aller à
l'étranger
il veut monter sa boîte il a plein de
projets il s'est rendu compte que
finalement la drogue est tous à la
délinquance est un engrenage et qu' il a
réussi à s'en sortir et il souhaite
maintenant il est d'ailleurs devenu
ambassadeur d'unicité du service civique
il souhaiterait bien que tous ses
copains de son quartier puissent
s'engager se rende compte de ce dont ils
sont capables comme lui femme yaël pas
du tout le même parcours fanien était
une brillante élève alors fania elle a
réussi à rentrer à dauphine et elle a
étudié étudié jusqu'à avoir son master
en sociologie et sciences de l'éducation
et puis avant d'aller en master 2 s est
dit faudrait quand même que je fasse une
petite pause pour réfléchir à ce que je
veux faire et donc elle aussi a croisé
la route du service civique d'unicité
elle a fait le choix de passer ces huit
mois parce qu'elle s'était huit mois à
monter un projet solidaire qui lui
tenait à corps quelque chose qui la
choque c'est les stéréotypes liés au
genre les stéréotypes entre hommes et
femmes
alors elle allait rentrer dans une
petite pépinière de jeunes entrepreneurs
sociaux et en service civique tous et
ils ont et elle a lancé des débats avec
les enfants là en école primaire sur
l'égalité femmes hommes
des témoignages comme loïc est elle
aussi évidemment a appris beaucoup et
elle s est rendu compte que sur les
bancs de l'école
elle avait appris plein de choses mais
pas du tout ce qu'elle a pu développer
ce qu'elle a pu acquérir au travers de
cette expérience elle se sentait elle a
rencontré des gens qu'elle n'aurait
jamais rencontré de sa vie évidemment
des loïc des gens qui viennent de
milieux beaucoup plus défavorisés que le
sien qui n'ont pas fait d'études et qui
sont plein de force et elle s'est rendu
compte que c'est ça la société et des
témoignages comme ceux de loïc et fania
on en entend tous les jours depuis 20
ans de la bouche de tous les jeunes qui
ont été mobilisés encadrés par unis cité
et ils sont plus de 15 mines on entend
ça que finalement vivre ensemble ça
s'apprend ça s'apprend par le fait de
faire des choses ensemble avec d'autres
avec des gens différents de soi
et c'est ça qu'ils ont appris et ils ont
appris et leurs propres compétences à
eux et aussi ce que c'est que la
différence et en quoi ça peut être une
force et c'est justement pour ça qu'on
avait d'ailleurs créé unicité il ya 20
ans convaincu que si tous les jeunes
consacrer une année une étape de leur
vie à faire des choses pour les autres
avec les autres notre société finalement
se répète plus fraternelle plus engagée
plus citoyenne et plus respectueuse des
différences nous venions découvrir le
service civil que clinton venait de
lancer aux états unis donc il ya une
vingtaine d'années inspiré notamment par
l'expérience d'une association qui
mélangé des jeunes des différentes
communautés culturelles aux états unis
donc des noirs américains des
hispaniques des blancs des asiatiques et
pendant une année en équipe
il les mettait en mouvement pour
apprendre à se respecter en faisant des
choses pour les autres c'est ça
l'inspiration c'est ça qui nous a
inspirés et sauf qu'il ya 20 ans on est
parti de rien avec pas de statut légal
pour ces jeunes pas d'argent d'état avec
la seule force de notre vision de notre
conviction et le soutien de quelques
entrepreneurs entreprises qui ont
accepté de s'engager avec nous et nous
allons finalement été chercher des bacs
moins 5 des bac + 5 des jeunes
bacheliers des jeunes croyants
catholiques chrétiens musulmans juifs
watts et non croyants agnostiques des
jeunes dans les cités des jeunes dans
les beaux quartiers et on les a
organisés en équipes en essayant de leur
dire et pendant neuf mois vous allez
oublier que vous venez de mondes
différents et vous allez essayer d'aller
aider ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin
des sans abri des personnes âgées
isolées des enfants dans les cités
ensemble vous allez essayer d'aider
d'apporter votre petite pierre et alors
là à ce moment là je fais une pause et
je vais boire on m'a dit que j'avais le
droit
donc le fait puisqu'on a le droit mais
même quand on n'a pas le droit on le
fait c'est ce qu'on a fait hier un temps
voilà et là je reviens
donc nous avons fait ça pendant une
dizaine d'années au moins
sans statut légal pour tous ces jeunes
et sans argent de l'état heureusement
petit à petit la force de conviction de
ces centaines voire milliers de premiers
jeunes pionniers finalement nous a
permis de convaincre les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé à leur droite et
gauche confondues
d'ailleurs c'était d'abord droite plus
gauche de lancer ce qui s'est appelé le
service civil volontaire en 2005 qui est
devenu le service civique que vous
connaissez aujourd'hui
enfin pour certains d'entre vous
j'espère quel est le bilan de tout ça il
n'y a plus de ce live voilà quel est le
bilan
cinquante mille jeunes mobilisés en
service civique en 2015
ils vont être puisque on n'a pas
complètement fini l'année 2016 ils vont
être presque cent mille en 2016
mobiliser auprès de dizaines de milliers
d'associations d'écoles d'hôpitaux de
maison de quartier de centre
d'hébergement de personnes dans la rue
deux collectivités locales
des dizaines de milliers d'organisations
qui ont accepté de leur donner leur
chance
95% toute satisfaction et puis
évidemment des jeunes qui derrière
s'engagent plus ce qui ne s'engageait
pas au moins un sur deux s'engage
derrière ils votent deux fois plus que
les autres et à unis cité où on a au
moins 75 % de jeunes qui comme loïc ont
à peine le niveau bac pouvoir 35% ont
n'ont pas atteint le bac 82% six mois
après retrouver un boulot retrouve ou
repartent en formation ils sont heureux
de nous ment un mouvement parce qu'ils
ont gagné confiance en eux alors y'a pas
de slide voilà mais vous allez me dire
tout ça est très bien ça existe c'est le
service civique
mais sauf que ça n'est pas fini c'est
pour ça que je suis là il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin
si on veut que ça devienne une étape
naturelle dans la vie de tous les jeunes
c'est pas cent mille jeunes qu'il faut
par an ces huit cent mille jeunes qu'il
faut viser par an et il faut pas juste
place et des jeunes dans des structures
sur des missions bidons
il faut quelque chose de qualité il faut
un service civique qui soit vraiment
universel connus et accessibles à tous
ou en bolivie
les jeunes sur est ce qu'on peut avoir
la slide après voilà merci sur des
missions collectives où ils peuvent
justement faire se rencontrer loïc et
fabien
il faut que ce soit des missions qui
leur permettent d'être là en tant
qu'être humain pas d'être là entre en
tant que technicien donc d'apprendre à
être et d'apprendre à être avec les
autres à être juste humain et fraternel
et il faut un encadrement de biens et de
personnes bienveillantes c'est ça qui a
permis à loïc de se rendre compte que il
était capable de quelque chose parce que
autour de lui il ya un encadrant
quelqu'un qui lui a dit qu'on avait
confiance en lui qu'on comptait sur lui
et aujourd'hui encore qu'on compte sur
lui
c'est ce genre d'environnement qu'il
nous faut arriver à développer
alors je lance un appel je lance un
appel à vous tous autour de la salle je
lance un appel d'abord évidemment aux
jeunes qui sont ici il faut vous engagez
que vous ayez ou pas fait des études
il faut vous engagez on a besoin de tout
le monde et c'est une expérience dont
vous ne sortirez jamais indemne vous ne
vous ne pourrez pas la vivre demain
c'est le bon moment quand on n'a pas
encore commencé une carrière
professionnelle quand on se cherche
c'est exactement à ce moment là qu'il
faut s'engager ces huit mois de sa vie
d'investissement je lance un appel aux
parents aux éducateurs donner confiance
à vos enfants vous dites pas ça c'est le
bats évêques dont personne ne veut vos
enfants ils en sortiront grandis il en
sortir aux différents et ils le
regretteront jamais je lance un appel à
toutes les responsables parmi vous mme
responsables d'associations de communes
les élus locaux des gens qui travaillent
dans des hôpitaux confier des missions à
des jeunes
je vous ai dit cent mille jeunes l'année
dernière il nous en faut 800 milles on a
besoin que vous ouvriez vos portes et
que vous confier des missions
intéressantes aux jeunes je lance
évidemment un appel aux chefs
d'entreprise au citoyen lambda pour
qu'ils vivent ce meeting soutiennent et
évidemment il paraît qu'il ya quelques
politiques ici autour de la table ceux
qui candidatent pour les élections
présidentielles futures ne sont pas là
mais ceux qui candidatent peut-être pour
les élections législatives futur
peut-être qu'on en a dans la salle tous
nos élus futur nationaux investissez
dans le service civique
arrêtez de nous
bassiner avec des idées de services de
retour du service national au service
militaire obligatoire
nous trouvons déjà des missions et de
quoi mobiliser les quelques 350 mille
jeunes qui sont aujourd'hui candidats
pour s'engager et qu'on laisse sur le
bas de la porte parce qu'on n'a pas de
mission pour eux c'est ça vraiment
l'avenir et unicité et nous tous on est
plus de 15000 maintenant on sera
toujours là pour vous aider à aller dans
le bon sens merci
[Applaudissements]